I respect you too boy hi there it's
senior reviews editor Peter Brown
standing in for a reviewer of Miguel
concepción to tell you about Madden NFL
16 capitalizing on the many strengths of
last year's installment Madden NFL 16
isn't the kind of status quo sequel that
made the likes of Madden NFL oh seven or
twelve forgettable this year's Madden
feels like a genuine acknowledgement
that different fans not only gravitate
to different modes but different play
styles as well it helps a great deal
that last year's Madden finally made
defense as equally compelling as offense
which means a lot to a series that used
to be known for past heavy offense this
kind of accessibility in Madden NFL 16
can be found through its many training
drills and more significantly in the
ever-popular Ultimate Team mode in fact
the first decision you have to make an
ultimate team is to choose your team
style whether it's speed rush offense a
pass rush defense or six other places
domes for as much as EA Tiburon has made
defense more appealing they still found
time to add new and practical options to
the passing game now quarterbacks can
elect to throw a hotly contested high
jump throw or a low throw for a higher
percentage catch by the intended
receiver players can take the high risk
on a run after catch or leap for a
highlight reel friendly aggressive catch
if oncoming traffic is an issue the
receiver can use a possession catch to
give the ball a tad protection
baby Packer these new features
positively add to an already robust
arsenal of offensive options and getting
the hanging these new moves is as
gratifying as it is when countering them
on defense if you have a large sample of
Maddon loving friends odds are that each
of you will have different issues to
vent about that could be a higher than
expected frequency of penalties or poor
pass coverage it doesn't help that zone
coverage is still way more effective
than man coverage in Madden NFL 16
though that's where the sliders in the
settings submenu come in which has been
greatly improved over last year's
version practically every skill and
referee decision imaginable is open to
adjustment last year's Madden 15 was
only the second installment in the
series to grace the Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 yet EA Tiburon had the
talent and know-how to produce the most
visually arresting football video game
to date the studio also managed to
narrow the animation gap between the
silky smooth on-field action and the
less fluid scenes on the sidelines after
a whistle but Madden NFL 16 still lags
from a presentation standpoint in some
areas other ea sports franchises like
FIFA and NHL have mastered the nuances
of broadcast quality visuals in his
defense EA Tiburon attempts at broadcast
emulation look like a positive
work-in-progress
we enjoyed watching the introduction key
players ring game visuals coexist with
TV sports CG effects and live-action
clips of the real player men 16 proves
that EA Tiburon isn't shy about
experimentation as this year's game sees
the introduction of a new team-building
fantasy football inspired mode called
draft champions along with picking an
active coach you undergo 15 rounds of
drafts each round limits you do a small
selection of random players of a
specific position that means you'll get
completely different teams every time
you restart it's a novelty free mode
that makes for a fine addition to the
suite of modes in Madden NFL practice
motor mains useful offering a large
combination of scenarios you can test
out over and over again until you get it
just right it's about the closest you'll
get to a real-life training candidate
and there's a vastly more useful way to
Train than say EA is disappointing the
shallow training mode in the recent NHL
games practice mode feels like a sibling
to the skills trainer mode the existence
of all these accessibility options prove
EA Tiburon confidence in reaching new
fans as well as former fans who haven't
played Madden maybe since the 16-bit
days skill trainers most notable feature
is the return of the gauntlet drill
series aptly titled the gauntlet strikes
back a nod to the fact that this is the
second year of this now popular mode
devoid of any throwaway modes or game
types that mean to pull a nostalgia
heartstrings Madden NFL 16 is both sin
Cybil and forward-thinking EA could have
made a bigger deal about Super Bowl 50
or rely more heavily on the appeal of
the Hall of Fame players in the game
instead EA Tiburon has focused more on
fans diverse play tastes as well as
making this one of the most newcomer
accessible Madden's in recent memory
points may have made the lead
insurmountable but just over a quarter
to play yeah it's tough sometimes you
get the situation like this